instead of taking a break before his
graduation medical student Randi
Cassell's is looking to get straight to
work
the soon-to-be urologist and other med
students have heeded his university's
call for help and will be assisting
doctors on the front lines of the corona
virus pandemic well those are patient
charts and help write notes and and call
and help make appointments and just help
ease the burden off of the doctors on
the front lines helping people during
scary at times and helping them get
better is why I chose to be a doctor not
only has New York's governor signed an
executive order to let medical students
graduate early he's enlisting the help
of retirees as well god Bless America
people have volunteered from out of
state to come into New York State I
thank them I thank their patriotism I
thank their dedication and passion to
their mission of Public Health
but as covin cases continue to rise the
city estimates 45,000 more doctors and
nurses will be needed in coming weeks we
really have to safeguard our health
workers this is going to be a marathon
not a sprint and we have to protect them
as best we can provide them with breaks
where they can really get away the
streets of New York have been unusually
quiet these days as all but essential
workers have been asked to stay home but
every evening at 7:00 all across the
city
New Yorkers listen have been coming to
their doors and windows and cheering for
doctors nurses and all first responders
everyone knows while streets here are
relatively empty emergency rooms are
full they're working so hard I've never
seen the ER because I'm familiar with
this hospital as crowded as as it was
dr. Sonny moon a licensed palliative
care specialist had left medicine but is
now volunteering at the hospital where
she used to work helping sick quarantine
patients communicate with loved ones a
lot of these patients are dying alone
because they're on isolation so for me
that was one of the other reasons I
wanted to help because I felt like I
could make a difference in such a
horrible situation that dedication and
community spirit finally giving New
Yorkers something to cheer about
christen salumi al Jazeera New York